[Applause]  Victor Oladipo is for payback  [Music]  to Lowry chance a tire take the lead  pile on the drive  stop surge swings it  [Applause]  ow  first lead since it was 35 34 won a  night in Toronto  11:01 Jeff  shot clock at five Depot - cows Gupta Oh  No along the sideline  [Applause]  wanna see  the end of the game  far sideline  the bull right alone  sideline didn't  Raptors  in a franchise  well straight for the  interracial sports histories  the longest winning streak in the  history of Toronto sports 12 games and  Wow an improbably scenario just played  itself out here remarkable situation and  that extra pass both the siakam  penetration and serge ibaka brilliant  tonight 30 points and look at his  defenses absolutely  assistants great job guys  and again straight up Bogut's  [Applause]  at a1c naka tremendous play unselfish he  drives it to the basket into Lowry and  then to Ibaka and serge ibaka 5,000 all  right big matchup with some bonus he got  it done